Speaker 1: Publican Party claims to
be against cancel culture number one
Number two The Republican Party claims to
be a big tent party where they welcome all
this different stuff. You know, different views,
different people, but they don't actually do that.
And there is a very interesting new article
that the Wyoming Republican Party is no
longer recognizing Republican Congresswoman Liz
Cheney as a Republican. This is the very cancel
culture that they claim to be against. Look at
this. The Wyoming Republican Party voted to no
longer recognize Liz Cheney as a member of the
Republican Party. The state parties sent the
State Party Central Committee's central committee.
I like that 31 to 29 vote followed similar votes
by Republican officials in roughly one third of
Wyoming's 23 counties. It's laughable to suggest
Liz is anything but a committed conservative
Republican, said Jeremy Adler, a Cheney spokesman.
The vote marks the Wyoming Republican Party's
second rebuke of Cheney following her vote to
impeach former President Trump for his
role in the Jan. six attack on the U.S.
Capitol. She is facing a primary for primary,
a quadruple primary challenge in Wyoming.
But what's very interesting about this is that
very uncontroversial things get you canceled by
the people who say, don't cancel the right says,
don't we don't do cancel culture. Cancel culture
is bad. What did Liz Cheney do? She voted what she
believed was what was her conscience in terms of
Trump's Jan. six impeachment. And she says Trump
lost. She still a Republican. She still voted with
Trump. I think it was 93 percent of the time. This
is a committed. Publican, a devout Republican,
but saying Biden did win, Biden did win is
something that can get you canceled by the modern
Republican Party. Now if this were reversed,
if this was if this was reversed, if you had a
Democrat who had crossed party lines to agree with
what Republicans were saying and Democrats voted
to say, this is not not a Democrat anymore. Fox
News, Newsmax. All the right wing media would do
a week on the Democratic Party has been hijacked
by extremists who have no tolerance for dissenting
views. They canceled. They do. Silence from the
national media on what the Wyoming Republican
Party has done. Now the truth is the Republican
Party actually was captured by extremists
starting in. You can go back to the 80s, certainly
by the time Newt Gingrich became speaker of the
House in 1994. It's a cult. It's it's the norm
now in the Republican Party, and Barry Goldwater
had had really predicted this. Barry Goldwater
said, Mark my word. If and when these preachers
get control of the Republican Party and they're
surely trying to do so, it's going to be a
terrible damn problem. Frankly, these people
frighten me. Politics and governing demand
compromise. But these Christians believe they are
acting in the name of God, so they can't and won't
compromise. I know I've tried to deal with them.
And of course, Barry Goldwater was right. And it's
been not only pastors that have taken over the
Republican Party, but just conservative Christian
individuals in great part who want to see a
Christian version of Sharia law be the ruling sort
of doctrine of the United States and extremists
of other kinds as well. Goldwater predicted one
piece of it, but not even really the full scope.
It's actually even worse than Barry Goldwater has
predicted. So there it is. Liz Cheney canceled by
the party that is about stopping the cancelation.
They claim the left is doing. We'll have more
on this on our Instagram. You can find that
at David P. David Pakman show on Instagram. You
can also follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.